danny duffy will make his tenth start of
the year for the royals and we're hoping
he could take
it a little deeper this afternoon yeah
little by little they're stretching him
out and you know he loves this
opportunity to pitch here in front of
the k
in front of his crowd
[Music]
and he cracks one to left field but
right out the left fielder edward
olivares
one out danny facing another veteran
josh donaldson
oh
in there strike three call by will
little
we just ripped that fastball at 95. look
at that cheese at the knees
and donaldson was looking for something
else obviously but you got to go
and griffin jacks making his first major
league start
does have a win 12 innings
how about this it's even better as it
keeps going on here i don't know but
fans continue to make catch after catch
and those lovely ladies there found
himself a souvenir
how about that came to the game thinking
hey look i'll just use my hat that
showed some skills i'll say
and he wins it with a walk
even if the royals fail to score in this
inning
they are working
griffin jacks to a nub that ball struck
to the left side fielded by
simmons
and he'll throw out salvador perez the
royal threat but do not score in the
first
and also the breaking ball so he's
having a tough time he can hit the
fastball
celestino blues one to shallow center
field taylor coming on can't make the
play as he lunged in forward it rolls
behind him celestino is going to make
second base standing and now he's in
scoring position two outs no score top
two
and a chance for luisa rise
he strikes him out
goes up with a 95 mile an hour heater
and gets his second strike out of the
day
now it's michael a taylor and
right-hander brings it home and a little
gork out into short right field he's
going to drop in for a hit
that's not fair michael taylor is that
fair right there no but baseball and
life are not fair
got him to chase
much better second inning for griffin
jackson
slider low on donaldson two house no
score top three ball no strikes on
donaldson struck out his first time he
swings and pulls a ground ball fare
inside third down the left field line as
it bounces off the sidewall and
donaldson slows his route to second base
and he's safe as he got his foot in on
the bag before alberto got the tag down
yeah there he's trotty i think he
actually got safe because he didn't
slide
but now here comes michael salazar along
with ronco baldelli
it did appear again rounding the bag
josh right now doing some light jogging
towards third base not a full sprint
walks head down back towards second base
hands on his hips josh ain't saying much
and ronco's doing most of the taco now
they're telling them to get off the
field
josh is walking off
donaldson will have to leave this game
rocco is going to get his lineup card
out of his back pocket pure law no score
two on two out top three and the one-two
pitch a ground ball chopped to first
this is gloved by santana behind the bag
we'll take it to the base jefferson out
it is only at back 32 to jeffers
and he'll take a walk and the twins get
their first lead off batter on base
and a base hit up the middle right over
the mound right over the second base bag
and jeffers will check in at second base
so the twins have something going here a
walk and a base hit now the twins in
business here two on nobody out here
celestino to bat
toward the hole
they get one and the throw to first is
wild coming in from third base jeffers
will score
[Applause]
slide step again
and driven to right field a base hit for
simmons
celestino around second head to third
[Applause]
and the twins aren't done yet a run on
the board now runners on the corners two
down for polanco
[Applause]
turbine to center and it'll die
between alberto and taylor coming in
from third of celestino and it's two to
nothing and now hanser alberto he fly
out to left field in the second inning
here's the pitch and he shows bunt
alberto with a good bun
and it's down the line
santana will take third alberto to
second base and you're right the bunt
works out perfectly now the royals down
two nothing in the fourth inning and two
runners in scoring position for hunter
dozier
and he goes up and hits this one in the
air gordon comes on dives can't make the
play the ball gets by him
and comes santana here comes alberto the
play at the plate they're gonna call
obstruction on simmons at second base so
it's gonna be a two-run base hit for
dozier and the royals have tied it at
two dozier's at second
base head right field
runner being waved around third
and
he's out wow a nice tag by jeffers the
throw was up the line but jeffers was
able to reach back with the glove
here's olivares and he swings and hits
one deep to left field into the corner
it is gone into the minnesota bullpen
my goodness then woke up the crowd here
and the royals having a big inning
olaveras
looking for his first home run of the
year he got it
and it was a no doubter he had a swung
on gun a slight breeze coming in from
right that's no effect in left and look
at that two hands on the back good
finish great balance touch them all
solaire back to first base
perez rips one down the left field line
and that's a fair ball
solaire is going to make it home as the
ball
rolls around the corner and the perez
double gives the royals a 5-2 lead
batter is hunter dozier runners at the
corners one down infield in about
halfway jax delivers and a swing and a
little fly ball
into shallow left center coming in the
left fielder kirilov makes the catch
tagging is salvi here he comes the throw
is offline and he scores
on a sacrifice fly off the bat
of hunter dozier the royals lead is six
to two salvador perez plays like a kid
with that enthusiasm as he crossed home
plate
he got some more running in he ran in
place to show off his skills his running
two down on the eighth and now here's
larnick you know they have found a
weakness a hole in his swing if you will
there's a ball deep to right
back and gone larnick with a home run
down the line and for larnick he's come
off the bench and delivered two hits
today
and it's a 6-3 ball game
power
fastball down it inside and pulled it a
line drive homer finds the seats in
right near the royals bullpen
scott barlow comes out of the bullpen to
close it out barlow got the save last
night in the royal 7-4 win
he did swinging a miss
he put it in the same spot
same result from nick gordon a swing and
a miss
and now here comes cruz
up the middle this should do it
alberto fires and cruz is the final out
and the royals have won the first two
games of this series
last night by a score of seven to four
and this afternoon at kauffman stadium
six to four way to go
scotty boy